extra extra read all about it a dog is
now the first-ever CEO of a technology
company Lauren what are you doing I'm
trying to market my technology blog but
so far I can't really tell if it's
working you know if you transfer all of
the data you collect with campaign
manager into Google bigquery you can
more easily tell what's working and what
isn't when it comes to your marketing
let's check it out okay
campaign manager is a web-based ad
management system for advertisers and
agencies that enables the management of
campaigns across the web in order to
access the data in your account you will
need to contact campaign manager support
to set up the data transfer files on
your behalf
these files will be hosted in a Google
cloud storage bucket let's get right to
it in the bigquery UI navigate to the
transfers tab and you can see the list
of already configured transfers now
we're going to create a new transfer you
can specify the source which in this
case is campaign manager you also have
multiple other Google data sources
available from Google Ads to cloud
storage to YouTube we'll enter a display
name configure any scheduling options
for the transfer and select a
destination data set now in the data
source details section information about
the cloud storage bucket and the
double-click ID will be provided by
campaign manager support you can also
enable notifications so that a
designated individual can be notified on
transfer run failures once you click
Save the data transfer process will
begin on a preset schedule let's switch
to existing transverse select our
recently creates a transfer and then
click on configuration you can see that
the source is campaign manager and there
isn't a schedule as we didn't create one
also the destination data set we
selected is displayed you can click on
run history to view information about
the daily runs of the transfer schedule
next we'll examine the datasets where
our campaign manager data lives and take
a look at one of the impressions tables
we can see a sample of the impressions
table data by clicking preview this
table has columns for advertiser ID
campaign ID country code states or
region and much more now let's take a
look at one of the matched tables which
is essentially a lookup table for the
IDS you saw in the impressions table you
can see that in the match table the
campaign IDs are matched to the
corresponding campaign name well all of
my data is now in one place but it still
doesn't tell me anything new now what
okay
now that all of your data is in big
crate we have the ability to run queries
on it to make connections that aren't
visible by just looking at the data what
are we waiting for
stories like dog CEOs need to be heard
let's begin to see what kinds of
insights a digital marketer might want
from this data a good example would be
to run a query to provide the number of
impressions and unique users by campaign
from the beginning of this year let's do
that the results show us just that
notice that we only see campaign manager
IDs though and no campaign names now
let's take this one step further by
executing a join on the impressions and
match tables and running the same query
this time we can see the campaign
manager names by date in addition to the
impression count and the number of
unique users marketing teams find this
type of information extremely useful and
all of these insights and more can be
found by using the campaign manager data
transfer service with bigquery look like
you're doing well now that I know I can
use the bigquery data transfer sir
with campaign manager data I'm able to
customize my marketing campaigns much
better and I have more readers than ever
and how's that dog CEO doing you'll have
to stop by the blog to check it out
thank you for watching don't forget to
subscribe for more great Google cloud
platform content
[Music]